Jason surveyed the scene the place was a
mess
broken glass scattered across the floor
small puddles of blood and chemicals
here and there and three dead bodies
lying in the middle of the room
Jason shook his head things had gotten
out of hand
real quick two of the scientists at bull
guns on the foundation team and in the
ensuing firefight all three scientists
were killed walking through the room
Jason spotted a piece of paper jutting
out beneath his shelf just the corner
visible he picked it up and let out a
sigh as he looked at it a photograph of
a family smiling happily in the nice
weather a woman in her late 40s with a
kind and caring look a little girl no
more than ten years old beaming like
she'd just won the grand prize in the
lottery and a man probably in his early
50s one arm around his woman's shoulder
and the other holding the girl's hand on
the back and very neat handwriting was
written we'll miss you every day your
away love Carla and Lily
Jason shook his head the two who had
drawn guns were probably members of some
shady organization looking to weaponize
or profit off the SCPs they acquired but
this man he hadn't fought and it seemed
completely surprised and terrified when
his colleagues started shooting he
cowered beneath the table and had been
hit by stray bullet he probably had no
idea what they were really doing perhaps
too excited about working with such
unusual samples to notice anything
suspicious Jason looked around the room
making sure nobody could see him and
pocketed the photo he took another round
through the room making sure he hadn't
missed anything important
and headed outside back in his quarters
Jason sat down in his bed and took out
the photo he looked at it for a little
while and then pulled out a small box he
kept in his desk he unlocked it and
opened it slowly looking over the
contents he'd have to get another box
soon
this one was getting full inside were a
number of items a locket a scratched and
cracked seedy plate several photos a
broken watch
two drawings in crayon and many other
small objects to anyone else just a
random assortment trinkets and junk but
Jason knew that each of these items had
a history each had been taken from a
site where the foundation had run into a
conflict that had claimed the life of
someone who's only wrongdoing was being
in the wrong place at the wrong time
they hadn't known why they were killed
and their loved ones would never know
the truth Jason knew though he had held
on to these things to make sure he would
remember the truth might be hidden but
it wouldn't be forgotten not so long as
he lived he understood all too well how
necessary the work of the foundation was
and why secrecy was so important he knew
that sacrifices had to be made but the
least he could do was remember those who
had been sacrificed for the sake of all
humanity